i was just looking at some videos of
women who are upset about how they are
treated on dates or something and by the
dating apps they're sort of outraged
that these apps somehow have permitted
these men to behave in ways that like
are quite caddish and it's like you're
literally on like a hookup act what do
you expect like
did people try to cancel your book
before it was even released yes they did
what happened there
well i i won't go into detail but uh
there's a small number of
very strange people who get their their
kicks from from doing this uh and we
live in this bizarre cancer culture age
and
so yes i have i have these people who
think that talking about sexual
differences
tantamount to somehow being hitler um
and they kind of run around you know
emailing people and
trying to get me cancelled and sometimes
when i give a talk people hire security
guards to protect me
and uh yeah i mean lots of women are in
this bizarre position is that i mean i'm
sort of joking about it but on some
level it's actually deeply horrible and
you know
who are these people anyway you're a
dangerous you're a very dangerous
looking woman
i know i'm terrifying
uh okay so do you think that there's a
crisis with masculinity right now
well i think we're always supposed to
say that it's one of these sorts of
cliches like masculinity is always in
crisis like ever since you know i
remember reading things sort of 20 years
ago masculinity was in crisis then and i
think in the 1890s it was in crisis um
and so on and so forth but yeah i mean i
i do think there are sort of a series of
things that kind of come together
to make
masculinity and being a man
seriously difficult and
a big problem both for men and for women
and i wanted to try and think about ways
in which men and women could get along
better and that we could also start to
talk again about what it is to be a good
man you know because this idea that all
masculinity is bad and men are somehow
you know inherently evil i mean it's
incredibly stupid it's not true right
most women have very lovely
relationships with men and friends who
are men and brothers and fathers and
there are men in their lives who they
really really love
and
you know what don't want to see
demonized by this very very generalizing
and stupid rhetoric
about men you know which we've seen a
lot of in the last kind of five ten
years i think so toxic masculinity
um
the idea that all men have sort of
somehow
got power and that they're all sort of
predatory they're all just kind of you
know unpleasant uh underneath um
so yeah i think there's a crisis in that
sense there's also a kind of bigger
crisis in terms of the economy and the
types of jobs that people are getting
you know the economy was deliberately
explicitly uh made into this kind of
knowledge economy under thatcher all of
the kind of um
sort of manual labor and industrial jobs
which were typically done by men
have been
eradicated
you know so there is a kind of crisis in
that sense as well you know what what
role do men have you know and the
serious aspect of this would be to do
with things like depression and suicide
you know like suicide's the leading
cause of death for men under 45 in the
uk you know it's insane it's like uh
there's a real problem here
you know with men not knowing what their
role is and not feeling that they've got
responsibility and they've got a place
you know and i think
in terms of our collective humanity we
should all care about that you know it's
if this is a question for all of us
um so yeah there's lots of different
ways of looking at um a kind of crisis
but yeah i would say we're definitely in
the middle of one and we need to kind of
work out together how to sort of resolve
resolve things is there a problem with
you as a woman writing about masculinity
well i do i do make a joke about it in
the book i do say obviously i don't
really know what men want
in the first place it's a kind of jibe
about freud because freud famously says
you know what what does woman want and
he doesn't know either so i think if
freud could have a go i thought well you
know i i can as well you can have a
crack in even the scales yeah so i but i
do provide a handy list at the beginning
because i did ask a lot of my male
friends what it was they wanted so i
actually do give a list and it was
things like a beer
and a shed and
[ __ ] and nigella lawson and you know
these sorts of one of them just to be
left alone as well yes
i know who that was um
but yeah i mean there is something kind
of like cheeky about this book right
of course it's like ridiculous um on
some level but i think there's also a
way in which we live in an era in which
there's more and more transparency right
men are writing about their lives online
and anyone can look at it right so even
if they think think they're talking to
the to each other or to themselves or
not not to women we can still read it
all right so part of my kind of dark
mission was to to go and find out what
men say to each other when they think
that women aren't listening and then
sort of report back
uh is it right to say that men have more
power than women do you think
it it really depends what we mean by
power
you know so i talk about status in the
book and actually how difficult it is
all of this language you know of alpha
beta sigma
um
incel cook soyboy there's all this
language which circulates in the
so-called manosphere i.e the quite a bit
of the internet that focuses on men um
and you know what is an alpha men a man
in our society right is it the strongest
man a lot of them are in prison right is
it the richest man a lot of them are
nerds right the question of status is
like not obvious right the question of
what power is is power succeeding on the
terms of this world well maybe but there
are other kind of values right there are
spiritual values there's the value of
being a good father there's the value of
being just a kind person
do you know what i mean like there are
many different ways to be
uh
successful if you like or to be good you
know and we often have a very narrow
materialist conception you know that
it's just about money or recognition and
actually none of those things really
make anyone happy they don't really make
men happy they don't really make women
happy either so
you know i've got a big problem with
liberal feminism as well the idea that
you know women getting jobs as ceos or
you know making money is somehow like
the be-all and end-all of feminism like
no it isn't you know i i think it's a
it's a very narrow image of freedom and
and all of those sorts of things so and
also women definitely have power in the
sense that they also have power over men
which is to say the power to kind of
you know manipulate and and give
affection or withhold affection and
lots of the things that men do are in
relation to women right not everything
but it but it's very obvious that
men care about women they care about
what women think they care about whether
women like them they care about you know
looking after them
um
and if we don't say that women have
power then we're reducing them back to
this idea of children you know
and we're not you know adult women and
adult men both have power they might
have slightly different kinds of power
um but they definitely both do well
ultimately women have the ability to
gatekeep whether or not that man's
genetic lineage gets to continue
which is you know about as fundamental
as you're going to get between survival
and reproduction you've got 50
one of the interesting things that i've
been thinking about a lot recently is
that there is an inherently masculine
frame that is
being put forward as the
admirable appropriate
achievable goal that women are supposed
to try and attain and that is you should
be a boss [ __ ] clap back you should not
settle for less you should get over your
last boyfriend by getting under the next
one you know it's a very sort of
masculine frame that this is being given
to that you should pursue
education employment status prestige in
exactly the same way that men have
typically done for a long time but what
that seems to me is to
take a lot of power away from women that
fundamentally want to have a family or
who take their sense of purpose and
belonging from being a part of a
community or doing things with people as
opposed to things men typically have
lean towards things but it seems like
we're saying to women no no no the way
for you to take your power back within
this society is to forget the thing that
you're naturally
you may have a predisposition to and if
you do choose to do that then you've
just been
you've fallen for the trad wife [ __ ]
conspiracy and actually what you should
be doing is working at a law firm
um yeah i think i think you know whilst
on the one hand we would love to there
to be kind of equal value valuation of
all different modes of life you know so
that whatever people choose to do we
would respect it you know unless it's
sort of i don't know being an arm
stealer or murderer or something but
whatever you know within a sort of frame
we would be like encouraging of you know
hopefully and we would value precisely
motherhood and fatherhood as well as
like getting a phd or whatever right so
but i agree with you that the tendency
and the kind of modern the current
situation we're in is to push women into
those sorts of um
roles and those kind of uh yeah sort of
um like you say
previously quite masculine positions of
being like
uh having sex with lots of people uh
being successful on the terms of this
world and all of those sorts of things
um i think there isn't enough discussion
enough realistic discussion for women
about fertility which does fall off a
cliff at a certain point and actually
the longer you delay it you know the
harder it is you know i don't have
children myself but i think that's that
should by necessity be a rare position
and not one that is kind of the
mainstream idea um and it's a very
complicated decision for women to have
children or not and there are lots of
you know some women can't have children
some women want children but leave it
too late because of economic situations
you know so um i think yeah part of this
is about revaluing what it is to be a
mother and a father because i think that
the culture genuinely
is very down on that and it's making it
very difficult for people to start
families particularly younger people
than me particularly millennials um who
are struggling to get access to those
adult things like property and
you know even renting and and getting a
job and all of that so
um yeah i i
given that i'm also kind of
anti-capitalist and i'm anti-consumerism
and i'm anti this kind of system
i don't see there's any advantage for to
women behaving like men in this system
because the system itself is inhuman and
um
you know makes us turn against our
fellow feeling and it turns us all into
competitors so like in the book i talk
about the way in which men and women are
encouraged to be more like brother and
sister
you know almost like rivals
rather than as in some other kinds of
relationship which would be equal but
different and those differences would be
kind of celebrated
how have we got to the point where
there's so much fear and mistrust of men
do you think
i think it's a combination of things i
think you know there's a kind of
pendulum swing we're about 60 years
after the sexual revolution
and i think a lot of uh people are
currently revaluing whether that was
actually a good thing or not
for either men or women right it seems
to encourage forms of irresponsible
you know behavior it um turns sex into
another kind of commodity rather than a
form of intimacy and bonding which it
actually is
uh you know it's it shouldn't be treated
in my opinion as something um casual
necessarily you know and i think the
more people have casual sex the more it
erodes
their love of of individual people you
know and the idea if you start treating
everybody the same you don't see
you know the the unique beauty of
individual people and you don't
necessarily feel any loyalty to any
particular person right so i think
there's there's the the sexual
revolution has pushed us uh in that
direction and it it might be beneficial
for like 20 of men who can have their
pick of 80 of women right which seems to
be how the data skews
roughly um but it's not really
beneficial for the average man or woman
to have this very very unequal um
competitive you know
driven by desire sort of sexual economy
um it's awful actually
um
so i think you know obviously there are
very high profile cases where some men
do terrible things like sarah everard
case would be a recent case in point
which brings up questions of what do we
do with
male violence and i think everybody
wants an answer to that question right
men are violent towards each other
they're violent against themselves and
they're violent against women you know
men are
unequivocally responsible for like 95
percent of all human violence right we
we know this um possibly even more but
it is an issue i so i don't think that
demonizing men and saying that they're
all evil is a good solution i think it's
a terrible solution i think it makes it
pushes men into a a state of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy do you know
what i mean okay well if i'm evil then
i'm evil um whereas i think if if we say
on the other hand that men can be good
and that we can all be better um and
that one of the other things i suggest
is that men need to think start thinking
of themselves a little bit more as part
of a class
you know class of people called men um
rather than or not only also as
individuals right of course we're all
individuals but we're also part of of a
sex you know i'm a woman you're a man
you know it's not to say that you're
responsible therefore for all other
behavior that men uh
you know commit or things that men do
but if we had more of a sense of looking
after each other in a certain way we
might be able to prevent
some of these things happening so like
if you had a male friend for example he
was starting acting out and i don't know
getting really uh all over the place
like maybe something bad had happened to
him you know maybe he was really
depressed or upset and he was starting
to to behave in a in a bad way you know
tough love like real love would be to
say you know mate sort it out like i'll
help you you know let's get help for you
whatever right and that's what everybody
needs at some point um you know
some people might not need that but
quite a lot of people run into trouble
in their life you know i certainly have
and you know i think it's really common
so
you know it's that kind of thing how do
people take responsibility for each
other care about each other more often
in a maybe a stricter way
i think the problem is that it's very
difficult to be proud of your
masculinity at the moment when
masculinity itself is pretty difficult
to define when
everything in popular culture is saying
that masculinity in the typical ways
that you used to define it is toxic or
somehow perverse or wrong
you've got companies like gillette and
um who else is it that's gonna work like
even well nice done it to do with race i
suppose but specifically gillette you
know under they're a company which is
built on masculinity in men undermining
principles of masculinity and then
from a personal standpoint you know when
the sarah everard thing
uh
like we need to be protected from all
men and then if men say well it's not
all men that's somehow seen as the same
as saying like all lives matter against
black lives matter it's the same
kickback that that you get
which makes
it it's difficult to not feel resentment
for the entire movement at heart and
that's you know it's a juvenile thing to
feel but it's true you know if i get
lumped in with a psychopathic
police
rapist killer
i think well i have
i have more in common than a with a
woman than i do with that person and
then when i hear that i think right okay
well [ __ ] you and i go okay no swallow
it this this is an emotional reaction
that's coming from a group of people
that are in a having a bad situation so
on and so forth
but it's not easy it doesn't co-opt me
into that movement and david buss the
evolutionary psychologist he had a look
at the stats around sexual assault from
men and there are a very small number of
men that conduct a massive number of
sexual assaults so it is not
all men
um absolutely and i you know one of the
the
points of the book is to actually to
look at these forms of resentment you
know both from women towards men and
from some men towards women right so i
look at the extreme kind of resentment
positions
um and say this isn't the way to proceed
actually you know you it doesn't make
sense to blame an entire sex for your
failings or to generalize in this way so
i agree with you um again the question
for everybody is how do we prevent these
terrible things from happening you know
is it how do we identify these
tendencies in this very small number of
men in particular um
and i don't know the answer to that i
mean that seems to me a question for
criminologists and psychologists and
also in the way that we think about
community and how we live together like
if we were living in a smaller community
and we all knew each other we might have
more of a sense of when someone was
behaving awfully or if there was
somebody who needed protecting from
themselves or from others
you know rather than this kind of more
atomized way that we do live in which we
we walk around a city and we don't know
people you know that we are surrounded
by strangers you know because i don't
think it's very healthy to live in
constant fear you know we've also had
two years of a kind of fear narrative
being promoted by the government which
they explicitly admitted and i think
this kind of
encouraging feelings of fear doesn't
benefit people at all it doesn't benefit
us
it does benefit you know i don't know
businesses who make money off people
ordering offline and you know off the
internet and you know a general sense
that people are isolated and lonely and
atomized you know and and none of that
is good so i think there needs to be
more open discussions more conversations
more listening more understanding
of both men and women you know and if
men or women get angry at a certain
point about how they think they've
they've been treated or something bad
then there has to be stages after that
you know that can't just be the you know
the only move why is it that we've got
this sort of very low resolution view
at the moment of people what is it about
the current world that's meaning that
it's
all men all women
all police all black people all disabled
people all into gender people
yeah i think it's a divisive logic of
the media in many ways right you know
we've seen people uh
demonized or characterized in this way
in terms of groups like it's very very
useful for the powers that be if people
feel divided among themselves like you
know i remember rave right in the 90s
and this was great because there was
this kind of collective experience you
know not everyone went to a rave i was a
little bit young but it was like an
atmosphere where you would meet people
who were different and difference was
cool you know and it was nice to meet
people who were different you didn't
think oh i'm different from that person
therefore they're evil and bad and i
must hate them you know it was a kind of
recognition of difference that wasn't
divisive and i think you know what do
the media want to do they want to sell
papers and they want to sell things so
the more polemical and the more
generalizing
what's polemical mean
oh sort of um taking one side in a very
fierce way so like a polemic is like a
kind of you know an angry screed written
against so so i could have written a
book that was like a polemic against men
you know i could have written i hate men
or whatever but it's not true right it
would have been a lie you know there are
many men i love uh so it would have been
ridiculous but you know it's a form of
writing if you want to say something in
a kind of over-the-top sort of way
and i think you know the media thrives
on these kind of generalizations and
these kind of like claims because they
precisely because people will click on
them and they'll be irritated and you
know
so i think
the more we step away from those things
and we think about what's real in our
own lives like the people we know
our friends our partners our families
you know the better
and i think a lot of this is also about
turning people away from their families
and dividing them in that way so i think
the family should be much more
i don't know prominent and celebrated
as a as a form of
even as a form of resistance against the
state and against the incursions of a
world that makes you want to think that
we're all enemies what about the
patriarchy
well i there's a chapter in my book um
which discusses this and i think i say
that i think the way in which it's
generally used in a casual way today is
completely meaningless uh if not sort of
actively unhelpful
um it doesn't really take into account
questions of class there are many men
who don't have power and however we
define
that you know there are many men like i
talk about the opioid crisis in america
um which is overwhelmingly affects poor
white working-class men you know in
their suedes and we know we've known
about that for a few years
um
and the suicide rates and so on and so
there is this kind of question about
well if the patriarchy exists where does
it exist you know does it exist in the
bodies of individual men you know are
you a patriarch you know are you
oppressing me right now
um but also i go back and look at the
original meaning of it so if you look in
the bible you have these patriarchs like
abraham and actually what patriarch is
is someone who takes responsibility you
know and looks after his family is
someone who is actually the adult in the
room
and actually we have a culture that
encourages both men and women to behave
like children and infantile demanding
toddlers for as long as possible you
know that's what consumer culture is so
and actually nobody really wants to take
responsibility because taking
responsibility for yourself might mean
you know getting fit and looking after
yourself and not acting like a dick and
taking responsibility for other people
would involve things like telling people
to stop you know like you've had enough
or let's go home now or whatever and a
lot a lot of people don't want to take
that role either
so actually where there's a sort of lack
of
patriarchy in the old sense which is
people taking responsibility
um as well as there being a lack of
actual fathers you know why do we live
in a culture in which it's okay for
fathers to abandon their children right
it shouldn't be okay at all
why is it
that
this
problem that we are seeing to do with
masculinity and this sort of man-hating
why is that accelerated so much within
what the last maybe ten to five years
was is it me too was me too the the sort
of
match that ignited this ah well i think
it was happening before that i mean i
remember a long time ago there were all
these discussions about whether men were
over do we still need men why don't we
just have a sperm bank or something and
you know
that was the real radical feminist
approach right wasn't it the 1970s or
something that every even the
non-lesbian feminists were turning
lesbian because they didn't they wanted
to prove that they didn't need men there
was always a very small minority and i
do talk about separatism in the book but
there's also forms of male separatism
like men going their own way and you
know this is also a small movement but
it's interesting to compare them
um
yeah and i it's weird actually because i
think the stereotype of the second wave
feminist as this kind of angry
man-hating woman was never actually um
true but now it is true so like if
you're a liberal feminist like you are
you do hate you've become a cliche of
yourself yeah and actually and actually
i don't think the second wave really did
hate men because actually a lot of it
was about getting rid of gender
expectations and that was also for boys
and for men it was like saying you know
we should all be able to express
ourselves more and that gender is
harmful gender as in social expectation
is bad for both men and women and boys
and girls right so it wasn't just oh
women need to do better it was like
actually if we change the framework
it'll be better for everyone um men
included so
i i think
i like i say i think i think the media
has encouraged this kind of you know
divisive
hatred which isn't real but does have
real effects
you know in terms of how people think
and i was just looking at some videos of
women who are upset about how they are
treated on dates or something and by the
dating apps
and you know they're sort of outraged
that these apps
somehow have permitted these men
to behave in ways that like are quite
caddish
and it's like you're literally on like a
hookup app like what do you expect like
so i don't know it's very it's very
weird but there's sort of there's sort
of like a permission given to
to i don't know be outraged um about
male behavior even in a culture in which
that's obviously encouraged so it
strikes me if you really wanted to meet
like a nice man and you didn't want to
have to go through all of this like
rigmarole of the dating apps and whatnot
like you'd be better off like going to
church or like joining a gardening
organization or taking up a hobby you
know like something in the real world
near where you live in which you would
meet people in a more random way
you know not through the app not through
mediation not through the computer which
has all your data you know but rather in
real life like people used to do
that's obviously quite a radical thing
to say that you shouldn't just meet
people online but i think a big part of
that is
we've nerfed the potential or most of
the potential for the pain of rejection
by using social media
and tinder and bumble and stuff like
that because getting ghosted on a dating
app is
painful but it's not as painful as
walking up to somebody in a bar
and then rebuffing your advances
especially as a guy remembering that 86
of women
say that they want the man to be the one
that makes the first move now if you
wait until the man does that in real
life the terror that goes through a
guy's head before he has to walk up to a
girl in a bar and say hi what's your
name would you like me to buy you a
drink that is akin to like jumping out
of an airplane and that selects for a
very particular type of man as well
there is a subsection of men that are
the ones that go up and do most of the
asking and there is a huge swath of them
that just stand on the far side of the
bar making shifty eye movement
desperately hoping that you're going to
catch their eye at the same time so that
they can sort of i don't know like
motion you over or something
no sure and i do talk about that the
changing fortunes of the pickup artists
you know the fact that it's moved from
real life to online you know and there's
the riskiness of the early days where it
was as you described but you know also
things like people used to meet their
future spouses at work
and now this is all these edicts about
flirting or you know asking your
co-workers out right and do people even
work in offices anymore or do they just
sit at home you know on the computer so
the possibilities for meeting men and
women you know men and women meeting
have become um
more difficult as well they become more
restricted they become more paranoid
they become more anxious and sensitive
so yeah i mean obviously i'm not saying
you know people who use apps are
wrong but i just mean it it's definitely
changed in some very negative ways and i
think
on some level we have to admit that life
is risk life is you know
it does involve pain and rejection you
know everyone's been rejected it's of
course it's horrible right but it's also
something that makes you stronger and
you know and and if you i think if
people
make themselves interesting and they
they have you know
like they read books and they have
hobbies and they you know they look
after themselves and they're good
they're visibly good with their friends
and family
like that's really attractive you know
but i also would say that women
you know are being encouraged too often
to think that they must find the perfect
man
right and this is also really dangerous
and destructive whereas actually if what
you want is a a life and possibly a
family with somebody who is stable
you know kind
you know it it's not going to be the
fantasy of an alpha it's going to be a
nice normal man who has all of these
social ties and these forms of security
and is thoughtful and loves you for who
you are so i think there might be a kind
of pragmatic
need
for people to just think well what do i
want what do what do i actually want
from my life you know instead of
fantasizing that they're going to marry
a prince
or whatever what did you learn about the
manosphere and red pill
um well yeah i suppose quite a lot all
these different stages that there are
and i looked i was quite interested in
this story of um roosh who this
pickup artist who's converted to
christianity
um and has kind of turned his back on
you know this
uh this life of uh anonymous
indiscriminate sex and you know it opens
up the question of whether
what was he looking for when he was
doing that you know what what is
actually going on in that kind of thing
i mean it seems a bit
um
imagine an awkward conversation where
you you've managed to to pull someone
and they've they've put out
and then you're like oh actually i like
you i want to have a proper relationship
i should probably let you know i use
these tricks i read in a book to get you
to you know like that's that's awkward
right and neil strauss obviously talks
about this as well you know it's
sex for its own sake is like a bit banal
actually and uh
so
yeah so i think they're not they're all
these different kinds of pills obviously
like
blue pill red pill purple pill black
pill black feels pretty good god pill
huh god pill the god pill yeah white
pill uh clear pill curtis jarvin um
so
yeah i don't know i mean i think i think
i was interested in what the forms of
resentment actually were like whether
there was actually material basis for
the kinds of resentments that we would
associate with the men's rights activist
right so i was prepared to sort of take
these grievances seriously and some of
them are kind of correct you know men do
uh dominate the most dangerous jobs for
example right if we're talking about
equality in the workplace um do we
really want more women to
you know work as tree surgeons or on oil
rigs or whatever like you know there are
obvious limits to when we talk about
equality you know in the workplace uh
and other areas of life
um
you know i i think to go deep into male
resentment is interesting you do end up
with like mgtow you know on the one end
like these kind of neo monks who are
like
men who are sort of like not religious
necessarily but basically saying i don't
want any part of this i don't want to go
down the dating route i can't be
bothered i think that women are gold
diggers uh you know they they point out
that lots of men don't reproduce and
lots of famous men um don't have
children and they kind of celebrate this
form of like i don't know wholesale you
know voluntary celibacy you're now part
of an illustrious group that stretches
back through history yeah
why did you find that most men joined
mgtow or were there some common trends
that you discovered for that i think
some of them were definitely um
upset by a particular relationship going
south and that this had kind of colored
their impression of women as a whole you
know and i think
you know like i say at the extremes
there are a very small number of women
who do hate men and they may be and and
a very small number of men who who do
hate women and they may think that they
have good reason for doing so i mean
obviously if you're a woman who's been
hurt all her life by by her family or by
men that she's met you might have some
ground for grievance right so i'm not
denying that there is harm i'm not
denying that people are upset and and
you know with good reason and sometimes
um there is justified resentment and
hatred um but i actually think that's
not the vast majority of people i think
those positions are very extreme and the
same would go for mgtow this is a very
small group of men um you know some of
whom are just not interested in women
right that's also fine
um you know and obviously the book
focuses on heterosexuality and
heterosociality so i so i explicitly say
i'm not talking about gay men or gay
women um
but i think the comparison with female
separatism is quite interesting you know
is it possible to live in a given that
we live in a very mixed world to live
separately you know what does it mean to
try to live
whilst minimizing your contact with the
opposite sex is there a difference with
how
the women separatists of whatever the
1970s
are
framed versus the mgtows of the 2020s
i mean i think they're both
maybe looked upon with some
amusement by the vast majority of people
um i think they're very interesting
ideas i think they're always
temptations or tendencies in human
thought and i'm sure at some point
everyone has thought god i wish i could
live without the opposite sex or
something and i mean one of the
interesting things i suppose i found out
was so sometimes men if they start to
sort of work on themselves as it were
they get fit and they go to the gym and
like initially for some of those men
it's about um
becoming more attractive to women but
actually the further they go down that
route the more they're just interested
in looking after themselves for its own
sake or hanging out with their bros or
you know being part of a kind of
masculine or male group um and it stops
becoming about women actually which
paradoxically would probably make them
more attractive if you do what i mean
but yeah so i thought you know there are
different kind of stages and phases but
i think most people know and want to
live in a mixed world but i do think we
might need to have a collective
conversation about
whether there should be more sex
segregated spaces and whether it's
actually better sometimes for men to
spend time with men alone and women to
spend time with women alone that brings
up some
bad histories though right of men having
holding seats of power not permitting
women into men's working clubs where
important and commanding conversations
were taking place
yes absolutely i'm not i don't think
there's a simple solution
to this question at all i think you know
we
women have sort of been in politics in
the uk or at least having representation
at the highest level for only about 100
years
so it's not been long
and i think it's it's not been an easy
ride
either uh i think they're very very
complicated metaphysical legal political
and philosophical conversations about
what it means to live in a world where
both men and women want
to you know to speak about
their own um position
right at the highest levels and want to
have their needs and differences
recognized and treated fairly in law
you know there's a very ongoing
contemporary conversation about what
even the words men
man and woman mean
um which is further complicating things
um so but i wonder if there's a way
which we could maybe revisit some of
those questions and say well
you know maybe some of these places that
we made into mixed things maybe it was
maybe that it's better if they we move
back to segregated
but i just think i think just enabling
it you know without without being given
the label of whatever awful version of
this from the past that there's a big
difference between having a
high-class
westminster
post-house of lords bar that only the
guys can go into
and
saying i want to have a snooker club
in
you know the west end of newcastle where
i can go with my mates and we can talk
about
guy stuff you know there is in many gyms
now there are women only sections where
girls can go and train and that's
because they presumably feel more
comfortable just being around other
women and you think okay well that's
that's cool but if you were to open a
mail-only gym
i think that that might get a little bit
more kick-back
can i just get you to flick your light
on for me nina oh sure
lovely thank you
that's right um yeah i mean i think it's
a it's a complicated uh conversation
right and it's got to be a collective
one but i also think there's a role for
like tacit agreements
you know like if we if if we if a place
is basically male dominated
you know we don't you don't need to
officially make it so but if it is in
practice more or less like that
then i think it should be left alone and
the same would go for women's places and
you know i mean obviously people can
privately associate with who they like
that's one of our great freedoms is
freedom of association and so you know
and i i just think it's kind of really
important because
you know otherwise we end up all the
time with in a mixed world and that can
be quite difficult as well and i think
men and women both need time to
themselves as well what do you learn
about in cells
um yeah so
i i again i try to sort of think of
think about it as sympathetically you
know again this is a group of men who
are demonized everywhere you look in the
media you know that this these sorts of
um few high profile so-called in-cell
murders are often used to demonize the
whole group and to say that anyone who
who reads intel forums or posts on these
forums is is therefore guilty by
association you know and this is a
common political tactic that we see all
the time now it's like well you know you
know this person who knows this person
or you read this therefore you know
you're sort of tainted and it's a very
bad political um and rhetorical gesture
but
so i basically said well in a way what
what do the in cells want right they
they want a girlfriend like is that so
awful i mean you know and actually
people like jordan peterson
you know who are very popular
very hated by the by the left in general
actually
i think are actually good for for women
because they're saying to young men stop
blaming your mother stop blaming the
fact that you don't have a girlfriend on
women in general sort yourself out tidy
room and all of those basic things that
like a father might say
um and actually this is this is much
better it gives people a sense of
freedom and autonomy it means that
they're not reliant on other people for
their happiness and again paradoxically
that would make it more likely for them
to meet someone and have a you know that
kind of life so
um
yeah i think the incels actually are
very uh sympathetic in the main
you know i think what and there's a very
good documentary called tfw no gf by
alex lemoya so that feeling when no
girlfriend where's it set in america
where she interviews a lot of these
young men who post on intel forums and
make memes and actually really funny and
really clever and inventive
and they they live in like terrible
places like they live in really
impoverished working-class towns where
all of the industry's gone you know and
it's really a question of class in a lot
of ways you know you've got these
liberal elites
having a go at
men living in deprived dispossessed
areas who can't afford to move out of
their mom's basement you know going haha
you know look at these sad young men
right and it's actually like no these
men are like
not sad in that way you know they've
already
suffering and struggling you know like
i don't know this idea that you're sort
of permitted to laugh at them is just
kind of
well there's something fundamental about
that right that
what you're laughing at is that as a man
one of the primary things that you
should be able to do is attract women
that's
why that's why the insult of calling
somebody an incel is supposed to sting
right primarily one of your functions as
a man is to be able to attract women and
if you can't that somehow makes you less
of a man it makes you kind of this sort
of sub group
interesting what you say as well about
jordan peterson so recently he went on a
podcast and they asked him
about uh what does he think about the
modern dating market some question to do
with that right and typically as i'm
sure that you've become familiar with on
red pill and manosphere places the
typical answer that you would
get or want to hear on those channels is
it's all about hypergamy women are
setting their sights too high they are
over educated they're overemployed
they're earning too much they need to
raise themselves back down they need to
lower their standards basically and
jordan said exactly the opposite thing
he said about men you know if you are
consistently entering into interactions
with women and all of the women have a
problem the problem isn't the women the
problem is you like you are the common
denominator between all of those
different situations you're the thread
that runs between them all not the women
and that's a really unpopular thing to
hear and yet this is a guy that only
three years ago was being lambasted as
you know the darling of the
manosphere who was going to co-opt
people into mgtow and incel and
objectifying women and so on and you
think
i you can't have you can't have it both
ways like the guy's either making man
better or he's making men worse and
from what i see he says things that are
uncomfortable for people to hear which
is take some [ __ ] personal
responsibility for your outcomes in life
yeah exactly which is why i say that
he's good for women you know that they
there is a kind of like feminist defense
of jordan peterson
you know and and i think that's
absolutely right and you know but he's
also kind of tapping into a kind of
christian tradition and
you know a tradition of kind of morality
and virtue monogamy
and monogamy and monogamy yeah which is
also kind of eroded by the current
culture you know which is consumerist
and hedonistic and you know so i think a
lot of people are coming to the
conclusion that there is something wrong
with liberalism you know we all need to
sort of look at what's happened
and where we're at and how we treat each
other um and maybe revise some of these
fantasies of freedom that we've been
sold do you think that the sort of
dominant liberal culture makes women
unhappy
i i think in some cases yes i think it's
it's not obvious that the apex of female
existence
um involves being kind of like well paid
and lonely and you know i i mean for
anybody because because we're human
beings we're social beings
you know and and so obviously i'm
against this system in general
um and i'm against it for men and i'm
against it for women you know and i
think
it's
yeah it's sad when we're
not
more sympathetic to each other and we're
not more in touch with each other and we
think that success is like getting a
well-paid job in the city that's the
peak of what you're supposed to achieve
in the modern era yeah i mean it's just
it's just rubbish and most people have a
breakdown at some point anyway because
they realize that it's rubbish
the um i had greg mcewen on the show
author of essentialism and he's been
paid to work with these huge companies
disney executives nike executive you
know the peak of the peak of the peak in
terms of people that have been hard
charging taipei go-getters he said he
was working with this one executive who
had said to him that um he'd been he'd
finally got the position that he wanted
board member at some huge company this
guy had been doing you know
80-hour weeks for 20 years
and greg sits down and they're gonna
have this conversation and he said um
my son won't talk to me
and greg was like well i thought we're
having this conversation you've just
made your board member thing he said
yeah but my son's left the house my son
won't talk to me
he's like okay um
what
what's the problem with this like
how can we move forward so well
it turns out that for the last 20 years
all i've been doing is working and i've
had my ladder leaned up against the wall
that i really thought that i wanted to
climb and now it turns out that my
ladder is leaning up against the wrong
wall and i now don't have a relationship
with my son and this guy broke down and
said well
i would
give it all back if i could have this
relationship with my child but you've
missed it and that child's now 20 years
old or something and that's gone you
don't get to have that relationship
anymore
yeah no exactly and i think a lot of
people are realizing what's important in
life and it isn't work it's your family
and your friends and you know looking
after yourself and enjoying nature and
being outside you know and i don't think
we need more people to do more things
you know we need more people to do fewer
things
you know like to sort of chill out i
mean of course there's always economic
pressures you know and that's another
side of it we need to think about ways
in which people can live and live well
and have families if they want to have
them you know without this kind of
endless struggle and churn and you know
just night there
why is it that any male movement seems
to get associated with the far right
yeah this is um this is an interesting
question i
i don't directly talk about this the
political dimension in the book but i do
that explicit like for a good reason
which is to say
i didn't want to go down this whole
route of discussing you know this um
supposed association but i think it
reaches absolutely absurd levels i don't
think it's true by the way i don't think
you know i think this is a kind of left
liberal smear you know i mean women who
say that women exist are now called far
right for god's sake you know i mean
this is like the use of the words nazi
and fascist and far right are so removed
from reality and actually offensive
historically you know the idea that
anyone who disagrees with this very
specific left liberal position which was
invented five minutes ago is like
somehow a member of the bnp or whatever
i mean it's insane right and there are
so many people who are now so
politically dispossessed including a lot
of women and like the whole of mumsnet
for example right are hardly you know uh
members of stormfront or whatever you
know what i mean it's like it's mental
so you know there's a kind of general
political problem with the rhetoric but
you know even something like nofap like
this movement for um men who want to
stop masturbating and watching and stop
watching porn which i talk about in the
book briefly and i'm you know i think
it's a great idea and it seems really
supportive um that's been now designated
a hate group you know you are kidding me
no no and you're like this is this is
absolutely mental you know this you no
[ __ ] no fap has been designated a hate
group a bunch of men that are focusing
on not touching their penis all day
are a hate group what do they hate other
than their own penis well i suppose the
implication might be that they they use
some of the same forums or that they you
know i don't know that they but they
must hate women because if you don't
want to masturbate to horrible images of
women on drugs you know being filmed
like therefore there's something wrong
with you and you're some sort of
misogynist i don't know it's mental you
know i think the other thing is like
people need to these groups these sort
of anti-hate group groups which are
actually themselves hateful and they
need to create nazis right they need to
say you know more and more people are
nazis because that's just what they do
like they need there to be all of these
apparently hate-filled people that there
aren't in fact you know they're just
people who disagree which is reality you
know um so yeah you have this kind of
like uh
hatred production industrial complex you
know where these all these people are
running around going like these people
hate and you know and you're allowed to
hate the people who hate that's the
other paradox of this so is it a case
the that calling someone far right is
now just a
easy to accuse difficult to get off you
piece of slime that can be thrown at
basically anybody that you
seem to have a viewpoint which you're
not very happy with yes right okay and
that's that's why men that decide to not
engage with women men that decide to do
semen retention that gym culture as well
i've seen is associated with a slight
like a a gateway to the alt-right going
to the gym
and you think [ __ ] hell so you i
heard you talk it's not in the book but
i heard you talk about the purity spiral
on another show can you explain that
cause i was really interested
yeah i mean it's not it's not my idea
it's obviously been around for a long
time i mean they're the first time that
i heard it so not obviously to me uh
which is why i need you to tell them i
just want to make it clear that it's
like i you know i didn't come up with it
um but yeah so so i suppose it's this
idea that in like every group or every
movement
um
there comes a point at which
participation is is somehow a pro
improved
by becoming better at being part of that
group right so let me put it this way so
like a weak group if you want to prove
your credentials in a group let's say a
religious group
you're part of a religious movement and
there are rules and principles in the
movement those people who really want to
do well would be very strict about those
rules right they would be like i'm i'm
following these rules i'm a better x
than you you know i'm a better cult
member than you because i'm more
adhering to the rules um and to
demonstrate my loyalty to these
principles of these rules i'm going to
start expelling the people who are not
living up to these standards right so
you create the out group you're like
you're in the in group and you start to
create the group you make the group
stronger by becoming purer and purer
right so you expel all of the members
that have you know transgressed or
they're not following the lords of a
letter but only the spirit so so a lot
of people have suggested that parts of
the contemporary left have become like
this
you know that actually
people's dead determination to adhere to
the rules whatever the rules are these
new mantras that we're all supposed to
agree with we're not supposed to
question them you just have to repeat
them uh this idea that they're
you know some groups are more oppressed
than others and we must kind of you know
focus on our attention on the most
oppressed and here's the list of who are
the most oppressed people
um and so some people get really
fanatical about doing that you know like
i want to be the best
leftist activist you know i want to
prove my credentials and in order to do
that then it will involve things like
expelling people you know hounding
people who disagree
you know manifesting your loyalty to the
group
and so on and so forth um but it becomes
like a kind of spiral because it sort of
starts eating itself you know and some
of these groups become like circular
firing squads you know where it's like
who will be left standing you know
because like everyone gets taken out
there's a
interesting insight from a guy that i
had on the show where he said that an
absurd ideological belief
is less about the belief and a lot more
about signaling to your in-group that
you are compliant and signaling to your
out-group that you are someone to be
contended with that people don't have
ideas ideas have people
yes i think that that's a very um you
know useful way of looking at it and i
think um i think it was rob henderson
who came up with his luxury belief shout
out rob henderson that's the rob
henderson bell for today
everybody loves that guy at the moment
he's hot he's so hot right now oh i just
want to cite him you know because if
people come up with a good concept you
know it's it's
it's good to try and remember who said
it you know what i mean because like all
these things circulate rob i told him
about your book today oh really i sent
him a photo i sent him a photo of your
book and i said you need to read this
and he said looks great going to read it
so oh that's that's kind of you well
they go you know so i think he was the
one who popularized this idea of luxury
beliefs which is kind of what you're
talking about you know so it's like who
can afford to say things that are
manifestly absurd as a demonstration of
loyalty like as you put it to the in
group and yeah
um so we need less of that and more uh
nuanced discussion more more more
recognition of of the complexity of life
actually and and
yeah is asking men what they want a
bit of a unique question because it
seems to me that women don't really
think about that mostly because for the
most part women
men are the protagonists sexually in
terms of relationships and even if you
look at the manosphere a lot of the time
they're not really that concerned with a
focus on raising up or understanding men
uh concerned with women's biases and
foibles and kind of pointing that out
and making sure that they know about it
yeah i mean i think
in the end what's
maybe a more realistic way of looking at
it is that what men want and what women
want is are deeply tied together you
know it's not that men and women
necessarily always want exactly the same
thing right because they're not exactly
the same
but none of us would be here if there
wasn't some kind of cooperation and at
least some of the time you know some
form of coming together and some
cooperation and some compatibility
however short-lived right like we're all
the products of you know those kinds of
encounters you know and hopefully it'd
be better to encourage situations where
people remained loyal you know looked
after their children and all of those
sorts of traditional things you know i
don't think anything is gained by you
know further eroding the family
structure or you know
so i i think we do get on i think it's a
it's a complicated game i try to talk
about it in a light-hearted way you know
i think the there are lots of different
games that men and women play all the
time you know and to reduce them just to
the mating game or whatever is is um
you know isn't true either like it's not
realistic it's not like what other games
well just linguistic games you know
conversations between friends you know
not all of the time we spend with
members of the opposite sex has anything
to do with sex you know we might be in
situations where we're at work and we
have to get along with people that we
you know we might
not otherwise spend time with but we
still have to have some form of you know
playful interaction
you know and i suppose i'm interested in
a world that is is
recognizes more of these ambiguities and
these kind of complex and often poetic
situations and and makes them
light-hearted right because men and
women might be
seen as the solution to each of the
sexes problems right we might think that
our quest for meaning will culminate in
meeting the appropriate member of the
opposite sex but but neither men or
women hold the secret to the solution of
the universe right it's that it's not
like one party knows what's going on and
the other doesn't like neither men or
women really know what's going on
it's like a collective process of trying
to work out together so in that sense
like it is kind of absurd and it is kind
of cosmic and it can be really nice and
fun and playful it doesn't have to be
grim and suspicious and you know as if
you're trying to crack some kind of
medieval code you know
it's interesting i am
i really don't know
sort of what
i don't know what situation has occurred
where so much humor has been lost from
society in like such a
short amount of time and
it's not even if you take it out of
talking about play and games and stuff
even if you take it out of non-mating
and put it back into mating stuff like
flirting as a a function a really
important function for young guys and
young girls to learn
how to effectively and attractively
communicate with the opposite sex you
know if you're in a place of work now
that's a no-no and there's a lot of
articles that i've read online talking
about why men should basically never
approach women i've spoken to guys this
was a real eye-opener to me i spoke to a
guy
18 months ago
uh who was 20 years old and we were in a
bar and i was saying hey man like the
two good looking girls over there should
we she'll go up and speak to them and he
honestly looked like i'd suggested that
we go and murder them he was like no no
dude no way no way but what do you mean
it was just they're not they're not
[ __ ] medusa it's just there's two
girls and um he couldn't believe he's
like no man i've been told i've been
told like do not do not approach a woman
if she doesn't make the first move
i thought well i mean
there's a lot of different reasons about
why the population crisis may be
occurring and that this may be the time
on the planet with the most number of
people that there's ever going to be and
maybe it's all because of that maybe
it's just because men are [ __ ]
themselves and not going up to speak to
women anymore
yeah maybe i
i think yeah i it's
i think we all have to ask ourselves
like who benefits from a world in which
men and women are too afraid to speak to
each other right it's not us it's not
men and women who benefit from that it's
other people who are going to make money
off your anxieties who are going to be
able to control you who are going to be
to feed you media narratives that tell
you that this sex is horrible and this
sex is horrible and this group is
horrible do you know what i mean it's a
way of controlling i think um
interaction as such you know like for
example with touch there are loads of
different ways of touching people some
cultures are really tactile you know
britain is not a very tactile country
but if you have even on top of that if
you have a kind of suspicion or a
paranoia about how touch might be
perceived like oh
what if that person perceives it as a
sexual thing when it's not you know and
so basically you end up with a world in
which everyone is too afraid to do
anything right but this is a terrible
world right imagine the most afraid
person hypothetical person the person
who wants the most safety who never
wants to be in any risk they have never
taken any never confront danger like
that is a bad world right and we don't
want the world to be modeled on the fear
of this hypothetical person right so
there has to be this kind of gray area
which is open yeah to misunderstanding
people making mistakes you know that's
why christian culture makes more sense
because it's like saying look
everybody's flawed everybody's broken
right no one's perfect
people make mistakes
right we're all capable of transgressing
but at the same time we can also forgive
each other we can also ask forgiveness
from each other from god we can atone
for our sins we can become better people
you know this is why i talk about
goodness in the book like it has to be
possible for men to be good you know
ideally we all want a world in which we
are all better people you know and it is
possible to improve
in loads of different ways right rather
than simply saying oh no this entire
category of people is just doomed to be
you know awful it's like a original sin
puritanical approach
um yeah exactly but again without the
forgiveness and atonement and all of
those things that are possible so it's
like it's it's awful it's like the worst
bits of christianity with none of the
good bits you know
and these people don't even understand
that they're sort of acting in this
fanatical way you know
so i think we just have to get on with
it and i think a lot of it is going to
be breaking away from the internet you
know i think there's going to be a third
summer of love people are going to come
together maybe this year after two years
of you know this pandemic nonsense we
will um you know have a big party one of
my friends morgan tweeted at the start
of this year uh where twenty percent of
the way into the twenties can we start
roaring yet because that's what we were
told right toward the back end of 2019
oh it's kind of been all
sort of withheld and puritanical and
everybody's been making judgments of
each other but the the 20s are coming
back you know
and then you know i i don't think that
covid
has
made that much of an impact when it's
come to the identity stuff it's giving
people more opportunity to be online and
and on the internet which has maybe made
them more neurotic but i like this is
just the path that everything was going
on in any case i know i mean i really
naively thought when the sort of
pandemic stuff started whenever it was
march 20
20. yeah um that people would put all
that stuff to one side and go oh
actually you know we've been fighting
over stupid stuff oh nina you idiot did
you think that a global pandemic was
going to remind us of our common
humanity well he's some sort of [ __ ]
simpleton
apparently yes but yes you're right it
did turn out to be some kind of like you
know uh continuation of the same but
worse no it's a catalyst it's a catalyst
we don't come together in times of
crisis true we split apart let me let's
talk about the is there a tension right
between
what women want from a man in a
relationship and then what it's sort of
what's encouraged to be signaled
publicly and popular views of
masculinity
um yeah i mean as i say i don't think
what men and women want is necessarily
that different in the end right i think
everybody wants to to to be good to be
you know recognized to um help their
friends and family you know to to make
enough money to live and and so on and
have a family if that's what they want
and that's this kind of thing right i
think so what humanity wants is more or
less the same um what men and women want
might be slightly different in some ways
but it's compatible i mean i mean from a
from a female's perspective that it
seems quite in vogue at the moment to
[ __ ] on men and yet these are women who
ostensibly need to find a man that they
can love that they can live in the same
[ __ ] house as
that they are attracted to a lot of the
time the sorts of men that they are
criticizing heavily online
yeah i mean this this i have to admit i
do find slightly flummoxing like i don't
understand what is going on where these
women are running around like hating
actively hating men or particularly male
behaviors
but they themselves are participating in
that culture you know like i say if you
want to find a good man they do exist
they just don't exist on like you know
uh on city dating apps right because
you're the kinds of men you're going to
find on there that you might be
attracted to are going to be playing the
field right they're not necessarily
going to be wanting to
you know settle down with you right
and and surely there has to be more
understanding of that like the reality
of that it's naive i mean i've been
naive before but it's naive to think
that you can go on these dating apps and
be like right well i want a husband
that's what i want so that's what i'll
get it's like
no you won't
it feels like the world's been made sort
of increasingly pure and malleable to
the stage where everyone has unrealistic
expectations about what life can deliver
them now so women want men to avoid a
toxic gaze but also 86 of women say that
they want a man to make the first move
or men are told that they shouldn't
objectify women meanwhile
50 shades of grey and only fans makes
millions off the exact same dynamic
yeah i mean i think one of the things we
have to think about in the internet age
is this question of attention right so
it's like where can you get your
attention from it should ideally be
enough if we want a monogamous culture
for one person to give you their
attention i'm not saying that one person
will be sufficient for all your needs
you might need friends to talk to about
certain things you might need other you
know family you know there's lots of
different ways in which you people spend
their time it doesn't all have to be
with this one person who can fulfill all
their needs and in fact that kind of
expectation is part of the problem the
idea that you're going to find like the
one you know it's like no you might find
someone who's like good enough and then
you build a life and it would be in the
building of the life that the love is
real if you see i mean it's not like all
at once that's why it's wrong to think
about it in this consumerist way as if
you're buying a product you know people
are not products you know they're
complicated flawed difficult brilliant
things you know and it's more about the
decision about
the mutual project like if you find
someone who wants to do the same thing
as you for the next 40 years fantastic
that's that's presuming that there's
something sacred in the relationship
though but there is i mean there should
be
you know a relationship with someone is
is not a product it's with a
everybody is unique it would be with
that specific person that you've
encountered however you've met them and
that you've both come to this kind of
agreement you know so it's both
pragmatic and magic at the same time i
mean and it might be really difficult
that's the other thing you can't bail at
the first sign of difficulty
you know that you can't return your your
mobile phone
this is what i meant when i said earlier
on that women are being encouraged to
adopt typically masculine traits in
order to deal with difficulties in life
because
that sort of shielded
walled off approach get over your last
boyfriend by getting under the next one
be a boss [ __ ] clap back don't settle
for less men are trash where all the
good guys are like you know they're just
this it's just this perpetual [ __ ]
meme farm yeah of things that tell women
not to settle because the disney
vacation of relationships has presumed
that any
minor inconvenience means that there's
something wrong with this you have an
international a global dating market
where you can with a 30 pound per year
tinder gold membership deposit yourself
anywhere on the planet and decide to
start matching with the people that are
in that region meanwhile the
relationships that i see most of the
young guys and go i run nightclubs right
for 18 to 21 year olds
most of the relationships that i see
those people having they're masturbating
with somebody else's body and neither of
them know it that's what's happening
yeah yeah i don't disagree and i you
know to actually have an intimate sexual
relationship with somebody
it you know it can't be done quickly
necessarily right
it's it's a complex thing and it's like
awkward and difficult and potential but
potentially amazing and you know this
kind of fast culture
mitigates against those sorts of forms
of intimacy and at the same time
everyone's afraid of being intimate you
know i mean i was speaking to people of
younger people about
dating apps and that and this young guy
who's very successful on them actually
was telling me like the one rule is that
don't catch feelings you know
like that that actually starting to care
about someone is like the worst thing
you can do and i was like
that's terrible what so you go out with
somebody and you really like them and
you you know you find them attractive
and but but to express that or to say oh
actually i really like you
that's somehow weakness well that's a
byproduct of
a liberal
sexual
society because inevitably you're going
to have lots and lots of sexual partners
or multiple sexual partners throughout
your dating time and if that's the case
you're going to end up
just using the person transactionally
and then inevitably you're going to move
on so the protection against being
ghosted and the pain of feeling
rejection is to never allow yourself to
care
and then you know even with
but that's like training everyone to be
a psychopath
correct
you know i mean this is like this is
very dangerous this is awful meanwhile
asking where's all of the empathy gone
in the world
yeah i mean we should care about each
other
i mean like that's that's what being
human is you know if we regard
everything transactionally then we're
just machines
and we're not machines like they might
want you to be machines but we're not
actually
your uh
left-leaning background comes comes
through with with this sort of stuff
because i don't know how much how when
you talk about the
sort of the capitalist
machine that is
profiting from
your inherent atomization and the
individual nature and the fact that you
feel alone and bored and require
dopamine
how much of that do you think's
coordinated
because there's this line from don't
look up in netflix
um which i thought was amazing and one
of the guys says
uh
the scariest part is they're not even
clever enough to coordinate the
conspiracies that you think
so how much do you think that companies
and um the people that are running the
show
are aware of the impact of this and how
much do you think that they just sort of
along for the ride on top of appropriate
trends that have happened to occur sure
and i think this is a perennial question
that anyone thinks who thinks about
what's going on will it always end up
with it's like are they malevolent or
are they stupid right it's like you know
everybody ends up in it and it depends
on how paranoid you're feeling
as to how far you want to take it in
each direction but you know so i don't i
don't have some grand conspiracy theory
about what's going on but i think one of
the better ways of asking this question
is to say well what difference would it
make given the material reality given
what we're talking about for example the
encouragement of psychopathy
you know this is a real material thing
that's happening right between men and
women between human beings we are being
encouraged whether by design or just by
accident to regard each other in this
way so in a sense it doesn't matter
whether people are doing it in some evil
malevolence sitting around a table how
can we program them i mean yeah at the
same time we do know that the elites
meet up and discuss what to do so you
know not everything is some kind of like
delirious weed fantasy you know like
that there is sort of reality to this
you know and we must be careful about
looking at who's got the money who's got
the power who's telling governments what
to do you know that that stuff is real
and you can find out about it so
at the same time it's like in a way that
question in our experience of our own
lives we can look at our own lives and
go which tools are working for us you
know how is this thing making me feel
you know am i feeling more or less
alienated when i use these apps you know
how does watching porn change how i feel
about women in general and so on right
so i think this thing about beginning
from yourself it's like to even think
for yourself in the first place takes it
sounds so simple but it's actually so
difficult to think for yourself
you know to actually say what do i
really feel about this issue
and it might be completely different
from what your friends think or what's
being said online you know to actually
give yourself the space and the time to
think something through properly
like this is really really important you
know and it might mean that you decide
to do something different from other
people or it might even put you at odds
with other people
you know but everybody has to do it like
everybody's life matters
you know we're not just cogs in a
machine we're not just puppets
you know we're not just
people going along with whatever anyone
else does we're all important and
everything that we think is important
everything we do is important because it
contributes to the whole you know which
we're a part of
so
i think yeah we have to start with
ourselves and the way that we're living
and i've had to do this you know i've
done this in relation to alcohol you
know it was destroying my life for
example you know lots of people struggle
with addiction at some point whether to
loads of different things you know we
live in a world that also pushes things
that are really bad for you
like all the time you know and people
have to be realistic and they have to
confront that and they have to be strong
and just because everybody else does
something if it's really bad for you
you shouldn't be doing it you know and
that's also taking responsibility
is that becoming more difficult
path to walk do you think recently
i don't know i mean i think because a
lot of people have struggled with
addiction of one kind or another
once people are getting to grips with
that however difficult it is you start
to recognize it in other people i think
you know and i think you have a lot more
respect for
for other people and for yourself
actually however difficult it is and i'm
not saying it's easy um it's hard to
take your life in hand to take charge of
it you know it's much easier just to be
passive and consumerist and go along
with
whatever is easy
it's hard to
take a stand you know yeah
talking about jordan peterson when i saw
him live in manchester a few years ago
someone asked him a question
that was basically the depth of my
consciousness causes me to suffer is it
or a blessing or a curse to feel
everything so deeply and i i really
really thought like it's
one guy's tweet from
four and a half years ago and it still
stuck with me because it's a question i
think that i've asked myself a lot as
well that you think well
regressing to some lower resolution form
of viewing the world
caring less thinking less paying less
attention that would make life easier it
would make relationships easier not
catching feelings you know not catching
feelings about life
would make life easier
and
is ignorance bliss like that's
you know that's a genuine question to
ask i think suffering is unavoidable i
think life involves suffering no matter
what you do and even if you try to
avoid it or especially if you try to
avoid it they'll still be suffering
right you're never going to be able to
not confront suffering in your life in
everybody's life there is going to be
at least a moment if not several moments
of severe suffering and i think the more
we understand that as a you know that
life is in some ways tragic but it's
also beautiful because it's tragic
you know and that if we understand that
suffering is something that we all share
and it's not apportioned out to
particular groups and some groups suffer
and others don't we all suffer you know
it's human to suffer
and i think that's a better starting
point i actually think that's
paradoxically a more optimistic starting
point
you know than saying oh we can avoid
suffering and we should protect
ourselves um because you can't
isn't that part of the conversation
between men and women as well that men
suffering a lot of the time is kind of
pointed at as well yeah but it's not as
bad as
the
whatever choose your intersectional
protected group
lesbian disabled person that's allergic
to avocados like whatever it might be
like they're they're having a really bad
day no exactly and i think there's
there's something extremely dangerous as
if there's a finite amount of suffering
to go go around and some people
suffering matters and other people's
suffering doesn't right that's just not
true
you know it's like suffering is
suffering right and it's shared by
humanity that's what i mean it's like
saying women should care about the male
suicide rate
you know because their suffering also
affects women right it affects all of us
well that's a father brother or son
exactly you know and
even collectively you know apart from
the intimate relations and all of the
pain that it causes
it's it's also a sorry indictment of us
as a species you know if you've got vast
quantities of unhappy people whether
they're women or men or whatever
you know it says something about us
as a whole we should be trying to think
about the reality of suffering
you know and then how do we collectively
deal with it and mitigate it where we
can you know but we can't avoid it we
can't fully eliminate suffering
this is where you end up with horrible
dystopias where like computers are
telling us what to do and you know you
all have to stay indoors and eat bugs
and live in a pod and you know
then you're safe
but finally that's not life
what are the masculine traits that you
think that should be retained then
yeah okay so i mean i say look just
because we're modern it doesn't mean
that everything our ancestors thought
was nonsense in fact they were like
really onto something so i talk about
things like courage
and loyalty and even the very idea of
virtue you know virtue as a word is
actually tied to the word for man like
via the same word the root word that we
get virility from
so so
morality or virtue and masculinity are
deeply tied together historically
and the idea of what it means to be a
good man like for the greeks would be to
be aware of your own strength but not to
deploy it recklessly right it would be
knowing having the judgment to know when
to be strong
like that's what it would be to be a
good man it would be to be courageous
but also
exercise judgment
you know not just to be like some kind
of crazy warrior or something like that
um so it would be things to do with
you know older virtues but also a kind
of fusion maybe of like the christian
virtues and the the classical virtues or
even frankly any discussion of virtue
whatsoever
it just to even begin that discussion
and say well what virtues should we all
be
you know uh encouraged to practice you
know and virtue is a practice it's not
just saying i'm a good person because i
think this and that it's it's a way of
behaving
you know that you have to work on and
you know you could people can change
their lives people can say
i was acting badly or i was misguided i
had the wrong idea i was an addict
whatever and they can go actually no i'm
not that anymore i'm gonna make a
concerted effort to do this better i'm
gonna be a better father i'm gonna look
after my health i'm going to you know
try and be kind every day whatever it is
you know everybody can make positive
changes
i think
the uk has a particular problem with
this
i think the uk has a particular problem
with high agency high sovereignty
behavior it seems to me to be
a very non-player character thinking
community at least in less cosmopolitan
places so in london perhaps less so but
you know you go to a newcastle liverpool
birmingham you know and you've got a
million people one and a half million
people or something and
no one knew is coming in no one knew is
going out the people are born live and
die there and their thinking patterns
follow that as well and it's my least
favorite part about the uk my least
favorite thing is the fact that it
encourages other it discourages other
people from doing new things from
changing their modes of thinking and
from striking out on their own but i
mean you know but maybe to play devil's
advocate i mean if those ways of
thinking are good and kind and you know
involve loyalty and fidelity and
friendship and
was taking responsibility then you
wouldn't necessarily need or want to
change them if you saw what i mean but
there's nothing good about um
the city or you know or london or i know
honestly like um in and of itself right
or doing random new things right just
for their own sake you can you can lead
a highly frivolous and hedonistic life
you know i mean it's it's
there are lots of different ways of
living for sure and there are more ways
of doing that in the city
but if you want to stay where you
somewhere that you love with people that
you love and you know even within that
situation you can
if you're drinking too much or if you're
you know staying away from your family
too much you can even make you can make
those changes you can make shifts and
alterations in your behavior however
small my point there is that i think
people who would just let's say that
they were drinking too much
if that's what the norm is and in the uk
we have a huge binge drinking culture
which you know my industry contributes
to um
if as soon as you start to peel off from
this and i saw this i did a thousand
days sober i did six months sober as a
productivity tool and i saw firsthand
the way that people respond they look at
you
alcohol is the only drug where if you
don't do it people assume that you have
a problem
like the only reason that you wouldn't
be drinking is because of a dependency
and
that is like a microcosm for
pick whatever it is that you want to do
i want to start a business i want to
travel the world i want to do whatever
there is a small town mentality that i
think has become extrapolated across a
lot of the uk and it's
stopping people from enacting what they
gutterally intuitively know to be true
and instead making them more prone to
just the race at the bottom of the
brainstem whatever the path of least
resistance is to do what everybody else
does and that hive mind thinking like
you know there are people out there who
would be able to make changes
and be positive influences downstream on
the people around them
that are terrified of doing it because
of the culture that would
isolate them for being the person that
decides to do something differently and
when i've been in america it is not like
that at all it is really really not like
that based on my experience i mean you
say that but i was recently in new york
and boston and people were extremely
conformist on the mask front and all of
the kovis stuff in a way that people in
britain are not that's interesting yep
yeah i can see that you know and so and
that kind of shocked me too and i know
it's it's even more politicized over
there you know in terms of red and blue
states and whatnot
um
so it's like so i don't know i mean i i
think
it may be also in the question of age
you know i think if people look people
do copy each other we copy we're very
mimetic right we we
we follow what other people do we if
someone likes something we're interested
in it because they like it you know like
we're because we're social creatures you
know and but i think
at certain points like if someone is
going down a path that's bad for them if
it doesn't go too too badly wrong and
they manage to survive
they
there does come like crisis points in
people's lives even if they're doing
what everyone else does and even if
they're sort of behaving in a normal way
i think at some point everyone will have
an experience with a with a crisis or
something bad will happen you know their
parents will die or you know some some
tragedy will happen that will cause them
to sort of maybe
think about their life you know
fundamentally
um
and that often brings about great change
you know so so i don't know i think i'm
kind of
um optimistic even on the basis of this
tragic worldview like i think i would
put it that way what about the future of
masculinity you optimistic for that
well like i say i think you know i mean
i i wrote a book a book is just a book
right it will be read by like 10 people
that's fine so i mean you know what as
much as we can do i think the vast
majority of things
that we do that matter are in real life
you know it's our real life interactions
with people it's not arguing online it's
not anonymous encounters it's
you know who we are and how we behave to
the people around us
you know
and that's real life
like
it's
um
it's about that and i think it's about
having more sympathy not buying into
these media narratives of resentment not
giving in to these feelings of
generalization and sweeping statement
and you know and from being reminded
that clickbait is just clickbait it's
not it's not real you know and the
feelings that you have towards your
father and your brother or your friend
or your partner are real like those are
the real things right as people spend
increasing time online that becomes life
though you know
screen time can outweigh
real life time no exactly and everybody
has you know anyone who spends any time
online and struggles with this question
you know especially if your livelihood
is tied up with it and whatnot or you
have to promote stuff or whatever
i mean i don't disagree but if if you
had to sit down if everybody had to sit
down and make a list of all the things
they valued right
i in the end i doubt that very many
people would put youtube
yeah my father you know what i mean
like
you know i think that would be very
weird if people did do that and i think
um
you know so we need to you know and it
is a dangerous time i think we're
heading into a more virtual world
and i think we need to be very very
careful and critical about that you know
for all of its advantages and benefits
and delights and shiny baubles like
we're still human we're still the same
in many ways as people from 2000 years
ago who didn't have the [ __ ] internet
you know like it's like
we've got to remember our ancestors
you know
because they weren't wrong about
everything
nina power ladies and gentlemen what do
men want masculinity and its discontent
will be linked in the show notes below
where should people go if they want to
keep up to date with you other stuff
that you do oh uh
i don't know i have a weird sub stack
where i write poetry poems i looked at
it today it's cool
yes uh but i think more mainstream wise
i have a facebook writer's page uh
i don't know there's just some various
videos on youtube and
stuff but i don't have a twitter or a
instagram or i don't know i'm like gen x
i'm sort of like between the boomers and
good for you and you're so i don't know
we're a bit in the middle we're a bit
weird i appreciate you nina i really
really like this book i think it's a
cool message
and um
yeah i think
it'll have some good impact i genuinely
do so well done with it oh well thanks
chris it was lovely to talk to you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace